now to a story breaking overnight
Israeli war planes have bombed Targets
in Lebanon and Gaza after a wave of
Rocket attacks against Israel it is the
most serious flare-up of violence along
the Israel Lebanon Border in nearly 20
years Ian Lee is tracking the latest
developments from London Ian good
morning
good morning Vlad tensions are always
high around the holidays in the holy
land and right now it's Ramadan Passover
and Easter it's a volatile combination
and the situation risks growing out of
control
and Lebanon Israel says the strikes were
in retaliation for dozens of rockets
fired by Hamas
this marks the biggest barrage by
militants from Israel's Northern
neighbor in 17 years
to the south in Gaza loud explosions
Rock The Strip as Israel says it
targeted tunnels and weapons
manufacturing sites
this Palestinian resident says we heard
a loud blast then another that shook our
house and shattered our Windows Israeli
Prime Minister Benjamin Netanyahu called
for calm at a cabinet meeting Thursday
night and added we will strike our
enemies and they will pay the price for
any Act of aggression
as Dawn revealed deep craters and broken
buildings the cycle of violence
continued
the militants fired another volley of
rockets Israel says its Iron Dome
missile defense system intercepted many
of them
this volatile situation erupted earlier
in the week after Israeli police raided
Al-Aqsa mosque in Jerusalem Palestinians
say they were praying peacefully Israeli
authorities say it was a response to
rioting
and just a couple hours ago the Israeli
military responded to a car being shot
at in the West Bank two Israelis were
killed and another is in serious
condition in what's being described as a
terrorist attack this sort of violence
that we're seeing has a way of
escalating into becoming a full-blown
conflict Nate
and thank you